uh right now there is a lot of buzz
around AI right u yes devops or
developer jobs are going to cut or
anything else so u in your day-to-day
activities or day-to-day
uh work how much part is driven by AI
okay so like Hussein works for 8 hours
or maybe he has some some x number of
tasks what number is driven by AI or
assisted by AI and what parts does
>> correct? So as we work in enterprise
level and also in house uh one of the
thing that we have to maintain is the
documentation of whatever you do and uh
so those things uh for those things I
completely I'm dependent on AI. I try my
level best to uh ask the AI to create
those documentation to create all the
points uh so that and it gives in a
really good manner so that I can use it.
Second thing I don't usually use it for
development because I know that AI tools
hallucinates it gives wrong answer very
confidently. So if I have to create any
infrastructure, if I have to deploy
anything, so uh my first place would be
to go to documentation. Terraform has a
very good documentation. Kubernetes has
its own really good documentation. So
for development, I usually uh do it on
documentation uh on official
documentations only.
>> But the problem with this approach is it
will be slow, right? uh because I
remember creating infrastructure like I
have been working with terapform since
like uh 6 to 7 years now like from
correct
>> 2018 or 19 I have been working with
terraform or maybe cloud formation for
that matter
>> so when I started to to create a
particular multi multi- account landing
zone I had to uh maybe I I used to take
like 15 days 20 days to script an entire
landing zone right 10 12 accounts, cloud
trail configs, multiple EC2 instances,
ALBs or whatnot. But with um AI, so I
and my team uses a lot of cursor, okay,
and now anti-gravity.
>> So we can we can create the same
infrastructure in like couple of days.
>> Okay. So I understand that you you
rightly mentioned that it hallucinates
the the downsides are already there but
there are few benefits as well, right?
So imagine 10 to 15 days days of work
was cut down into like 2 days. Okay.
>> Correct. Yes.
>> But I was able to do that because I had
the experience, right? I was able to
write the correct prompts and if if uh
if the tool hallucinates or it doesn't
give the required output I I I was abled
enough to make changes to